Dropbox has 400 million users now yes
who are they where are they the vast
majority of our users are actually
outside the US so some more than
two-thirds and it's been that way since
the beginning because people use Dropbox
again not just for stories but for
sharing and that's been at the heart of
how we grow those 400 million users how
many of those are paying customers most
people are using the product for free
and if you need more space you can buy
more now Dropbox is an 8 million
businesses that's up from for 4 million
you can just maybe a year and a half ago
two years ago and we have a hundred
thousand paying business customers who
are like the biggest fortune 500
companies that you signed up the vast
majority of the fortune 500 are using
Dropbox in some capacity but there's a
lot of household company kind of
household name kind of companies using
Dropbox from Under Armour's the world
Hyatt Hotels and what every quarter
we're adding big new customers what's
been the biggest challenge in terms of
penetrating the enterprise I think that
you know businesses every technology
kind of goes through this this curve
we're in the beginning people are a
little bit unsure about it and I think
in the last couple years it started to
flip where actually people realize
actually it's safer to have our
information and services like Dropbox
and then and in the cloud in general the
same way that you know we don't put our
cash under our mattresses anymore and
the bank does a pretty good job of
taking care of that